did you see the meme that they posted on
twitter and it was me
and you and uh adam22 and vlad
uh someone posted like a meme of all
four of our photos and they said this is
hip-hop media
yeah yo yo that was [ __ ] hilarious
they used the worst photo of me ever it
was i was like oh
god that's even worse not only was not
only where
was it the the idea of the photo but
then a bad picture on top of it
my main issue that i took with that was
just like
i know there are people who don't like
me i know i've said things that
people hold on to and rather than
thinking of something that you may have
done that they liked or
ten times when that you did something
they have like they remember that thing
that
made them uh not like you but like it
was just such a lazy assessment you know
like that was just of course listen
i'll take you and i being thrown in a
category together because they're
actually legitimate similarities you
could point to
right right right right and i don't know
what their relationships are so i don't
want to put you in a bad spot
but where you get to comparing us to
adam 22 and vlad
and i get adam 22 and vlad going
together because they get people to say
some semi-incriminating
crazy [ __ ] like i get the whole op thing
but
you and i like two kind of dj nerds
right right
respectful of the music and culture i
just don't that was such to me uh
that was a lazy but very funny it was
funny i just loved why like everyone
like was like defending
i feel like everyone was defending you
and me on twitter it was so
funny i was like we got some defense for
sherlock
not these guys by them yeah yeah it was
pretty funny it was pretty funny man